a Peter Charlie when we hear of the
great scientific discoveries yet to be
made chemistry rarely features highly as
this dog had its day well I never
thought that chemistry is being a dog
although my favorite molecule is nitroso
ether and if you've seen some of my
presentations it is a dog bit of a dog
that molecule wags its tail and I think
the dog community would be a bit
irritated by that sort of contention but
nevertheless um I think it's fair to say
that chemistry is natural subject I mean
the great breakthroughs with that we
understand what a bond is ok you know
that knowing Fineman said that the most
important thing to be passed on to other
generations if all other knowledge has
been lost was that there are little
things called atoms and at long
distances they attracted in a short
distance they repelled and into nuclear
reaction went to separated atoms and so
that's the potential curve that's
chemistry and so it's downhill a bit
from their own because chemistry is that
we are all made of these things um and
then Dalton put together the conclusion
now atoms existed and then basically
chemistry started then there are
exciting breakthroughs with benzene
things of this nature structure you know
and then i would say that DNA is a
molecule as well and so that's chemistry
we could the discovery of DNA could
quite easily have been a chemistry nobel
prize indeed hemoglobin which is also a
big biological molecule was a chemistry
prize of max per us and and so we move
on
we realize that chemistry is sort of
subject and other overarching subject
which now has major impact and in
material science in condensed matter
physics and in molecular biology and i
think one problem is that chemistry is
losing out there because it is chemistry
but the cutting-edge chemistry now is
being subsumed into other areas and I
felt for quite a while now that the
traditional structure of universities is
counterproductive and that instead of
basically chemistry panton physics
departments and engineering with bombs
there should be departments in which
basically nanotechnology which is
chemistry of the 21st century is being
carried out and so I think there's a
valid point here and I I think it this
presents a problem in education because
I think people who run universities and
government don't really appreciate that
they see the cutting edge advances in
condensed matter physics and this that
the older nanotechnology or molecular
biology or in materials engineering and
don't realize that it's chemistry and I
think that will present a problem in the
future because people going into these
areas will have very poor chemical
understanding and and chemistry is a
very rather unusual subject I think in
that it's very complex systems that we
make work we may not know exactly all
the details of a chemical reaction but
we know that if we heat it up or we slow
it down by cooling or we add a bit of
this and now that we can move it in a
certain direction we have some rough
theory theoretical feel of how things
are operating and then we we put a
chlorine in or
meaning the electronegativity and things
that I this nature and we skew the
process to the way we want it and so
Vice Chancellors at universities seem to
think that they can do science without
chemistry and that's just ridiculous
because I think chemistry is now
chemistry grounding is more important
today than it ever has been and I think
that if universities Cup chemistry
departments that some have done this is
infinite stupidity they should recognize
that science has changed into it
extremely interlocked cross-disciplinary
subject where you can't do
groundbreaking work without an
understanding of how atoms stick
together so you've hit on something
that's I think it's very important it's
not that it's how this day is that it
isn't recognized and it's sort of a
hybrid between you know the Tasmanian
devil or whatever is a hybrid sort of
these animals are hybrids and they they
do need chemistry because it's
fundamentally we do have to stick things
together